five to shoot a minute and a half to
play that's a bomb
oh my god
that's why coach schatz wanted hassan
laying back off the screen
[Applause]
he stays under control he gets to his
spots and he just rises up over the top
of people
lillard rising up but he misses from the
outside oh that is
really deep davey and lillard makes it
look
so easy
he takes two
lillard defenders long range damian off
that line
quite a bit he's got seven to fire on
top to lillard fumbles it away
shot clock at three has the defense in
front
one shot right
and he knows that so curious to see what
decisions he makes
moving forward on screen and roll dave
gets the foul
and it's going to be a four point play
the hard way back come the blazer great
job
by zach to stay in front oh here he goes
dame from kissimmee florida nails that
one
coming up the american express halftime
report what
three lillard
one dribble over half court and i raised
he was in bend oregon look at that man
oh
man that was a beauty five to shoot
a minute and a half to play that's a
bomb
oh my god oh ridiculous
damian lillard how did you get a
shooter's bounce like that
put 43 points on the horn in the period
a three from graham back iron rebound
trip
up the day at the buzzer buzzer
oh my goodness what up it's your boy
adam lefkow did you like that content i
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher